ben oui est-ce qu'il est riche que vous
auriez pu faire que vous avez vu dans le
film alors que vos gamins vous auriez pu
soit entêté tricheurs toi non oui
d'inventer un tricheur est d'ailleurs
tiens à te prends au mot quai est ce que
tu peux te mettre monsieur latouche la
rsa devrait rapidement monsieur latouche
et tu fais un quiz les enfants contre
moi j'enlève vous n'auriez vous allez
voir ils s'en fichent et je vous met une
tannée vous êtes avec l'instant quel
classement chéri 4e 4e 3e 3e 5e jour
dont je suis fan de toi je suis fan de
toi c'est vraiment mais le problème
parce que on peut pas être fun tous les
deux de l'un de l'autre je vous dis tout
de suite fabuleux toi j'aurai ta pour
toi si tu comprends pas comment ils sont
pas tombés amoureux de signal je ne
comprends pas comment ça se paie était
sympathique et donnait les belles belles
belles un peu chiant aussi des fois
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
edit c'est mon épaule et c'est monsieur
latouche c'est oui ça mais s'il a tiré
la new labour et sion ok l'année
tu as eu lieu la prise de la bastille
monsieur ducobu 1900 wissant à 1589 pas
vous avez triché pour cyril quel animal
a pour nom latin firn à meaux cannes
je répète quel animal a pour nom latin
sphyrna mokarrab alors
réfléchir le budget le requin marteau
[Applaudissements]
un parc où les marchés ben oui j'ai la
solution politique pour les enfants
comment s'appelle l'actuel premier
ministre les enfants et on philippe pour
les enfants question sport pour cyril à
l pays à organiser la coupe du monde de
football de 1938
quel prix
batta
je vais des peuples de langues ou paul
géraldy vous n'avez vous pas gerra d'une
merci je vous ne dites pas c'est raté
c'est dégueulasse
c'est
l'apogée radi allez vous occuper
tyrannie merci à la montée de tension
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes eu que des blessés si on
continue sur pénalité pour les enfants
svt pour les enfants combien de pâtes
bon les ariégeois lui vitesse bien joué
8 avec un ipad ça fait 3 points à 2 pour
les enfants quelques questions
littérature pour cyril qui est l'auteur
du poème intitulé le pèlerin passionné
alors juste avant que répondre et nous
jeu il ya un message je crois qu'il ya
un message de gérard jugnot qui joue
dans le film très bien là qui m'ont
envoyé un message et je répète quand
même l'agression juste avant qu'on voit
la vidéo du jura oui qui est l'auteur du
poème intitulé le pèlerin passionnés
d'accord salut ducobu salut tout le
monde c'est monsieur qui triche je peux
pas et avec vous ce soir parce que je
fais du yoga en ce moment je fais
beaucoup de gages pour être plus zen
la respiration j'inspire j'expire
j'inspire j'expire voilà shakespeare
voilà bonne soirée et à bientôt et c'est
pourquoi je vous embrasse tous je laime
genou et d'exceptionnel dans le film et
gérard tu sais que je t'aime fort et
j'espère qu'il va devoir bientôt donc
mais fantastique m'aviez posé une
question je répète qui est l'auteur du
poème intitulé le pèlerin passionnés
je serai pas william shakespeare à à
tricher c'est la bonne réponse mais pas
la voix la banqueroute ce qu'ils sont
des tricheurs
je sais pas comment ils trichent
maîtrise mal à cacher sur littérature
pour les enfants allaient qui a écrit le
roman les misérables de victor hugo
c'est que tu le savais pas je savais
mais j'ai eu mon cerveau un peu lent
donc auquel se joindra concession
géographie pour cyril qu'elle massif
montagneux situé dans le sud ouest de
l'allemagne dans le land de bade de
wurtemberg qu'elle massif montagneux
situé dans le sud ouest de l'allemagne
dans le land de bade de wittenberg du
bassiste pas fait attention
la réponse je pense que c'est la forêt
noire
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la bande à mon avis il ya des mecs qui
veulent se venger
alors question culture générale pour
cyril alors pour cyril tu me regardes
c'est moi d'abord c'est pas les enfants
abandon vous êtes assure mathématiques
pour les enfants excusez moi une veste
coûte initialement 200 euros le vendeur
me fais 50 % de réduction
à combien va j'ai acheté la baisse 0,6
je pense que la question va être dur
donc il faut que sa mère serait dur oui
question culture générale pour cyril
qu'elle sous quel nom est plus connue
tenzin gyatso est-ce que avant de
répondre je peux vous demander un petit
truc où vient de m'envoyer un sms
précisant que ma voiture est très mal
garé oui est-ce que je peux aller
l'année c'est ce que je peux l'aide à
passer j'ai très peur de prendre ap pas
les images il veille sur des budgets
oui ma voiture oui ma voiture s'il vous
plaît oui ma voiture
[Musique]
j'aurais vraiment de seconde
oui j'aurais vraiment deux banderilles
bonjour ça moi oui c'est que c'est quoi
ça j'ai mis mon la mala parce que je
suis vraiment je suis en émission mais
je vais me déplacer juste après vous les
jolies c'est moins dangereux d'attendre
si un peu quand ils vous avez vu c'est
celle sans dire son nom de succès
d'allaoui d'accord si bien je me gare si
l'on apprécié merci beaucoup merci
[Musique]
mais bon j'ai pu gérer excusez moi ouais
j'ai pu gérer ses 10 voilà la réponse
cyril c'était quoi la question que se
répète la question est quels noms les
plus connus
tenzin gyatso ce serait pas le dalaï
lama
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur